hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
al queen of york in his treatise on
virtues and vices when he's considering
the main kinds of vices is going to rely
on the schema very explicitly of the
eight capital vices which is coming from
ivagris ponticus and john cassian and
then proceeding into monastic literature
a very useful schema which will
eventually be supplanted largely within
the west by gregory the great's
reconsideration of these in his morality
on job on a very very popular works in
the monasteries which reduces them to
the
seven deadly sins that i think many of
us are much more familiar with
and in talking about some of the
vices or sins that are particularly
concerned with how we
value ourselves and how we compare
ourselves to others
it's important that we think about this
one envy in particular which is in the
seven deadly sins
but is not in the eight capital vices i
will say this however
john cassian
who does not include envy within those
eight capital vices
does talk about envy and so alkawin's
design
choice to actually address envy in here
makes a lot of sense and we can
associate envy and vainglory and pride
together
as as three
vicious dispositions that have some
things in common with each other now he
has an entire chapter
on envy chapter 22 and he says something
really interesting here
he uh brings up this this famous passage
death entered into the world or the
circle of the lands if we want to be
quite literal through the devil's
envy coming from the deutero
book of wisdom
and he tells us because he envied the
heaven to a terrestrial human that means
he's envying human beings being allowed
to go to heaven he sought in what way he
might lose it through the transgression
of that mandate which the creator had
decided for humans and then a little bit
later uh he's going to tell us that the
person who envies
is like the devil who through envy
ejected humans from the felicity of
paradise
so envy leads to all these bad things
and we're being sort of like the devil
in being envious
and he tells us that
nothing
can be more
miserable or or bad or contemptible than
envy nequius is the word he's not saying
that envy is the most evil
but it's the most worthless it's it's a
particularly
bad disposition and why well because
envy takes the good
and turns it into something bad
but it doesn't just do that
outside of the person who's envious it
does it within the envious person they
look at the good of others or they're
literally
tortured by torquorettor by the good
that others enjoy so instead of taking
joy in the good that somebody else has
they view that as something bad and bad
for
themselves so he says
what it does not have itself it envies
other having it is the enemy to all good
things
and it doesn't have to be the envious
person doesn't have to look at others
good as somehow affecting their own and
it's a kind of wrong
mode of comparison
um and you know the envious person is
unable to be charitable
and where there's no charity nothing
will be able to be good so it's a way of
taking the good in the world and that of
others
and screwing it up within the little
tiny world that is oneself
vainglory uh is not a term that we use
an awful lot these days but it was you
know real preoccupation going back by
the way
earlier than christian authors it's also
talked about
you know by
the earlier philosophers under different
names
kenodoxia kenos means vain or empty
doxia is glory or
you know the value that others place on
you ivana gloria is just how we
translate that and it has to do with
striving after praise from others now
not all striving after praise is
necessarily bad you know when you're
doing good things
uh and you want somebody else to weigh
in and give you feedback that's not
necessarily vainglory it's when that
becomes the
primary motivation
for doing it and you know
there's two chapters actually that have
to do with vainglory chapter 25 titled
about not seeking human praise is
completely about vainglory and we'll
come back to that in a moment but there
is also a chapter later on in the
treaties about canadoxia that is
vainglory so he says vainglory is when a
person strives after being praised now
notice
in his good things
doing good works
qualities that you have
and the person
wants to be
praised
for doing the good works and that is the
primary
motivation so they're not interested in
doing the good works
for the sake of doing good works or
because they recognize the goodness in a
prime example is giving alms to a beggar
and why do you give alms to the beggar
well you know it could be because you're
like that person is destitute they could
really use my help or it could be i i
want to be a big shot and look like i'm
a cool person very generous so i'll give
to this beggar but if nobody's watching
me maybe i'll take the money back or
i'll not give to other people that's
that's vainglory and people do all sorts
of stuff
motivated by vainglory right
so you know he brings up the example of
um
you know the person who
um here we go
he says
the lord says amen i say to you they
have received their reward people who
are doing good things just to have
everybody else look at them and it could
be good in the sense of like helping
other people it could be praying in
public right all of that if it's being
done for the sake of show
is is really vain glory and you know
that's
again it shows a mistaken understanding
of goods and bads uh wrong
prioritization
and it shows a wrong
relation of comparison to other people
what about pride superbia
it might be easy to mix this up with
vainglory you might say how how is pride
and vainglory different i mean
we often talk about pride itself as
vanity right isn't that one of the
seven deadly sins well actually vanity
is vainglory uh but pride is sort of
outside of it as the beginning
of all sins at least in gregory the
greats
accounting of it and there is indeed
this biblical verse that says that pride
is the beginning the onyxium of all sin
so that pride is in a certain way
lying behind
all of the rest of them it's sort of
like an undertone and pride and
vainglory are very interesting there's a
comparison that can be made
these are
vices
that ruin what is best in us so you know
the vainglorious person is doing good
things the prideful person does have
good things about themselves you can
even start to become
vainglorious or prideful
about your other virtues you can be like
oh look at how generous i am you know
maybe you're not even being vainglorious
about you're just being prideful you're
saying i'm more generous than everybody
else or i am realizing human potential
better than all those other schmucks out
there who are not doing it right because
they're motivated by vainglory even even
vainglory and your lack of it can become
a source of pride and so he tells us at
the beginning of the discussion of the
eight principle vices
pride is the queen of all evils through
which the angels fell from heaven which
happens from contempt
of the mandates of god
and he says it also happens when the
mind is raised about its good works
and thinks itself better
than others when actually
it is worse now it didn't start out as
worse
it becomes worse
through
that very
pride
so it takes something good sort of like
what envy does take something good
and ruins it sort of like what vainglory
does right does good actions ruins it
but in this case
it's a setting oneself up above others
and then thereby falling
below others who are not themselves
prideful
um
you know he tells us that uh
um
pride a person can take pride in their
good works and thus they lose through
pride what they had through charity
so you know the school the the
he says all pride throws into the depths
as much as it raises itself into the
height so much deeper it falls as much
higher it is elevated he who's lifted up
through his own pride is condemned
through the justice of god before the
ruin of a person
his spirit is exalted so there's this
very interesting interplay between
higher
greater
lower worse that is involved in pride
itself so the mind being raised by its
own good works ignoring the the you know
mandates of god there's another way that
he talks about pride
leading a person astray
obstinacy which is a way of translating
kontu makiya
we could also translate this as a
contempt disregard
despising one's obedience to superiors
and this you know could be connected
with god but you could also think about
this as connected with one's earthly
superiors so he says people despise
obeying their lords right so that that
is indeed a significant problem
now each of these is a very damaging
disposition in its own right but they
also lead to other problems he tells us
that pride for example
leads us to
disobedience
presumption obstinacy contentions
heresies
arrogance
and why would it lead to heresies
because heretics high racist means
choice
choose to take on a certain perspective
that excludes the rest of the community
and they say i'm right i'm the one who
knows better than all of you dummies you
know and so these are the things that
that stem from pride what does vainglory
itself lead to all sorts of other
problems as well
he says that um
boasting right if you're being
vainglorious you've got to have
something to brag about right arrogance
disdain discord desire for empty glory
and hypocrisy simulation of good works
right
um
what about envy does envy have any uh
products or
you know
bad things that that it leads to yes it
destroys
charity within us
and there are remedies for this as well
so he tells us that envy
has some some uh ways for us to deal
with it right um he tells us let nobody
lament the good of anyone else at all or
from another's felicity be made sad i
mean you can remind yourself that if
somebody else is enjoying something good
that doesn't actually harm you it's not
making you
worse off right and
you know humility can help out with that
he says a man is great who conquers envy
by humility and then destroys discord by
charity so the charity that's driven out
by envy can be restored through humility
and then having charity again
what about vainglory right i mean one
thing you can start doing is thinking
about why you're seeking out praise and
then
not seeking it out in the same way and
there's actually two remedies that he
talks about in chapter
34
the medicine of this disease is
recollection of divine goodness
through which all good things are
conferred on us which we seem to have
right
um there there's a sense of
thinking that
um we don't need to honor god but if we
understand things properly according to
alka when we realize that everything
good that we have
however we may have worked on it it
doesn't come from us ourselves there's
no self-made person
god has given us the very talents the
very dispositions the very you know body
that we work through so that can be one
part that that would be
quite helpful recollection of divine
goodness and then he says also the
perpetual charity
of god himself
in whose praise we ought to do all
things whatever good in the world we do
and we ought to desire rather to be
praised by god than by any other person
so we can look at god's own goodness and
charity and say well i should be like
that not like all these other people who
are in it for the praise right what kind
of person do i want to be
and then we have
pride itself how do we
deal
with pride itself
humility humility is the most important
virtue
in dealing with pride and it doesn't
mean like thinking less of ourselves
than we actually deserve it means
rightly understanding who we are
and how valuable
we we are so that's the remedy that can
help us out in dealing with this and you
notice all three of these
which are considered to be some of the
worst of the deadly sins or capital
vices they all have to do with
wrong understandings
not just intellectual but but also in
our hearts
about who we are and
what's good and what's bad and what we
should be
pursuing and valuing
you